quick question let's start with the hard
stuff right out of the gate here
if i was to ask your husband whether you
were on the naughty list or the nice
list this year what would he say
i think he'd say some of both
[Laughter]
i deserve anything i get a holly dolly
christmas was a number one album on your
christmas list this year
well i was hoping something good would
happen because i had to have something
to do
during all the lockdowns and also i just
got creative started writing songs but
i got so many things out there now i got
enough for presents for everybody
and spend a holy dolly christmas with
everybody this year
[Music]
so let's talk about those collaborations
um miley now
does miley have the ability to say no to
you when you call
you know molly would say no to me and we
both had times where we
wanted to do something together but we
were both working on a different project
but she had to sing on this christmas
album she was working on her own project
i said
i'm not going to ask you to put it out
as a single i know you got your own
thing
but you have to sing on this album with
me you and billy ray because you're like
family and i'm never
probably gonna ever do another christmas
album so i said you have to just sing on
this song she said well okay dolly
i'll do it aunt dolly were you able to
be in the studio
with these people or did they all have
to do it remotely
they had to do it remotely because we
could not be
you know in the same studio but do you
sort of wish that you coulda
hung out for an afternoon with michael
buble i certainly do
and we did talk a lot you know on the
phone and we talked a lot with all the
zoom stuff that you do
what's to do
[Music]
when life is good again i'm going to get
with all these people and i told them i
said look we can't do a christmas
special this year which i would
love to have done i said maybe next year
i can get all those great artists
and we can you know revive the album for
christmas next year and
add some new and additional things and
make a special next year so
you just roll your punches i just
believe in going
going as you go you can't give up you
just kind of fit yourself into
whatever's happening
be as productive as you can be when did
you realize
that you were such a part of so many
people's traditions over the holidays
well i have loved christmas all my life
and always wanted to do either christmas
movies or christmas specials
and i did an album of course with my
friend kenny we did a christmas special
so there's just something about me that
just says christmas
because i love all the sparkly stuff and
i kind of look like i might have tinsel
on me all the time anyway
but i just love the fun and the family
and the music i love everything about
christmas